it's that time to turn your great idea
into a reality and you can do that with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project if
you want to showcase your work or if you
want to sell products of any kind they
have beautiful templates and the ability
to customize just about anything so you
can easily make a beautiful website all
by yourself but if you do get stuck it
happens to the best of us they have a
24/7 award-winning customer support team
that is there to help you out so head to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain welcome to not too deep I'm your
host grace Helbig today we have Darby
Stanchfield with us you know her from
lock and key
you know her from scandal and you're
gonna get to know her as a lovely
maternal energy woman she's gonna teach
you the right way to cut a grapefruit
which if you didn't know you were doing
it wrong you're doing it wrong
also we learn about how a girl that
grows up in Alaska entertains herself
with no access to other people or the
Internet it's surprising enjoy this
episode of not too deep with Darby
Stanchfield grace you wanna hear
something crazy
oh wait you first at the streamys at the
streamys many years ago on scandal and I
presented an award and you were like
co-hosting I think yeah it's a big deal
and I was like what are this dreamin
yeah how was that experience for you
because I still ask what are the streams
a very curious award show the internet
folk that is very lovely and also now I
feel like I didn't go to this pastoral
in this past year but because you're
still asking
yeah I'm still questioning cuz it's one
of those things are you show up and you
really have no idea what everyone is up
to who everyone is there might be
animals there
lately more popular than anyone else
completely I think I ended up with a
plate of sausages yeah that makes sense
that makes sense for an Internet Oh a
good show thank you for being here I'm
very excited I just started locking key
which Netflix so graciously tells me I
need to watch every time I open Netflix
which is that lovely I love that they do
that I love it lock and key is very
curious to me because it yes tell me hey
look it seems like it's gonna be this
like Narnia like kids fantasy and it's
very creepy well creepy yeah it's it's
not just it's not for kids
technically yeah well kids can't I mean
yes it's a fantasy it is it's based on
some best-selling graphic novels that
are straight-up gothic horror oh so this
is toned way down and it is a show that
the creators them they paid a real
specific attention to the tone to make
it beware like 14 year olds 13 year olds
could watch us it's very heaven you're
cool I can imagine being a teenager
watching it being like this i watch it's
also creeped out yes a safe sense of
eeriness everywhere did you read the
graphic novel or take a look at it when
you got cast in this or previous to that
I did not I I mean I had done a little
research when I had the meetings but I
had not I was not really familiar I'd
not peruse them and of all the
characters and then a graphic novel mine
is probably the most different I mean
I'm I look the most different right and
she and him and my interpretation of
Nina Locke is probably the most
different okay other characters and that
was on purpose I mean the this show
Locke & Key has they've tried to make it
to other times really rocks and Hulu
both made pilots so Netflix is the third
try yeah and they really were sort of
adjusting like what worked what didn't
work how do we translate this I think it
was challenging ultimately they found
the right I think place to land it's
kind of a mash-up of the graphic novels
but the creators of our show gay
me the comics and just said you don't
don't take a literal translation because
in the comics Nina's completely drunk
the whole time she can look at her
children she's got a leg brace she's got
she's got cleavage I don't mean there's
so many ways that must be as an actress
freeing in that sense to be like here's
the source material but you know take it
with a grain of salt we want you well
that was a night it was a nice thing for
them to sort of say at the beginning but
on top of that Joe Hill who wrote the
graphic novels and Gabrielle Rodriguez
he was illustrator yeah they were also
incredibly supportive they came to her
said a lot whoa he signed comic books
for me but they were they watch dailies
and they watch the episodes and they
were really vocally very supportive
about how our adjustments were and what
we were putting out the work we're
putting out and that ultimately makes
you feel like oh okay yeah I can relax
that's when the collaboration seems to
be the smoothest when everyone's kind of
respectful of each other's right art and
artistry that they're bringing to a
project we all want to make this work
yeah that's nice yeah and also it's very
it's one of the things I noticed just
like going through your social media and
everything it's cast so well because you
guys truly look like a family we do
don't we it's eerie which is the most
flattering thing because I think those
children are so beautiful I mean I
shouldn't call the children Connors like
in his mid-20s yeah they're so beautiful
oh it was very cool to watch me like
this are they okay this is movie magic
what is what's the feedback bang because
it just came out a few weeks ago I guess
yeah and you know you you shoot and
you're in isolation in this like bubble
of making this project and then it gets
released to the world in a binge sense
290 bi-weekly based up like ten episodes
globally yeah and that's been on social
media that's been all right yeah it's
been great it's we people are watching
the show we've been in the top ten
in every West yeah for the last three
weeks I believe so it's getting watched
a ton is getting bitched binge done
I keep hearing people are like oh I'm
gonna binge it a second or third time
Wow
so that's all very exciting and so so I
mean the silver lining in the self
quarantining that we're all doing for us
right now is like this is a perfect
activity for you right you don't even
have to use sand hands on it yeah you
can just finish yeah exactly yeah where
did you guys shoot it we shot it in
Toronto oh you did yes most of it in the
pilot and in the finale we went to Nova
Scotia we went to Lunenburg Nova Scotia
which is like a couple of hour flight
and then a couple of hours by van and
then you're out in this small marine
fishing town I mean it's beautiful like
the environments are very very beautiful
yeah I like it I mean it's you know it's
it's faked for Massachusetts but it has
a really beautiful East Coast yeah like
and the nautical thing of that town and
um also we started shooting in November
and it was crazy
winter there with tons of snow so we
were shooting in below freezing
temperatures and added you know added to
all to that you know we're always very
real wising and working on something
that is you know based on a graphic
novel and has like fantasy elements to
it that must be very different than you
know shooting something like scandal
oh it's who couldn't be more opposite
yeah and it felt like it was great it
was new it reminded me of Theatre in the
sense which is your background just my
background yeah in that with the special
effects you can't see right anything and
they didn't even really have mock-ups
for us so it's described you know the
directors had you know they had
storyboards and what it would look like
but you're reacting to something that's
not really there and so it's like
theater and then you know a lot of in
theater a lot of it is the fourth wall
and you're and you're reacting to stuff
that's not you know hold Ukraine
old-world yet had that element to it
so you're going to exercising your own
personal create exaggeration yeah
totally yeah I think the thing that
grounded the experience for me is I feel
very connected to this cast they're all
like everybody you know I wasn't sure
you never know but like if people are
just gonna phone it in and you know I'm
gonna be on my phone the whole time and
but everybody was really into telling
this story so that anchored me in terms
of the relationships and getting really
specific with each kid yeah to create
this real family which anchors the whole
thing and then and then you know we
happen to like fall into a evil magic
mirror that could be happening somewhere
in the United States and we don't really
know that's right but in here it is
interesting that you say like when you
go into these cast projects you know
you're all selected and put into this
weird bubble and working together that
you don't know how everyone's
temperament is gonna be together
how did when did you first meet the cast
as you guys do like chemistry sessions
together or did you all just meet first
day on set I met everybody at a table
rate we had sort of a first day with the
table read and lunch and a series of
meetings I was the last to be cast a
lock family and I know that like Connor
lives in Toronto so he was already there
and I think and there were everybody's
from all over millions from England and
OH
Jackson's from Arizona so everybody flew
in sort of at different times and I
think they I actually think they got
hangout time before me oh and and so I
met them then but it was it was great I
mean they're each so different and on my
relationship to them just as people is
so different and I and the way that I
really approached this was like not to
bulldoze like oh I've done seven you
know she's an example like a hit show
and this is how it's done and I'm gonna
just instead I was like I'm gonna sort
of let them show me what they each need
or respond to thise and or how to
connect to each of them different
like Oh real mom also like a human being
yes me like you know yes if you're going
if we're gonna play a family like how
you know if I want them to trust me to
just kind of let them show me what that
is yeah so that was instinctual yeah but
they're but they're also happen to be
fantastic the bonus yeah and then also
their real moms are amazing women oh so
you know TV mom like we all ended up
having dinners together well that's way
every 3-4 weeks when there's we had time
off that's great that's all you could
ask for and I'm sure from their point of
view they're walking in with someone
that has such you know resume and
they're like please let her be nice okay
let's go back to the beginning you were
born in Alaska Dutch yes Kota Kodiak
Alaska from Kodiak Alaska yes how do you
describe that place it's it's a lot like
Matheson Massachusetts is a small
fishing town everybody knows each other
yeah it's a very small small small place
it's an island it takes couple of hours
to just get to the mainland by jet
bye-bye propeller jets model jumper
plane to get to Anchorage so you're out
in the middle of nowhere and you know a
hundred years ago when I was born up
there there was there was like one
channel on TV and there was no internet
and there was just like hardly any radio
so it was a very isolated way to grow up
so how did you
so what sparked your interest in like
the arts I guess I was basically doing
that up there cuz there was nothing else
to do my sister who's my best friend
she's a painter okay all we did
basically our whole childhood was like
pretend like make stuff up yeah make
pretend and then also paint and draw Wow
that was it that sounds very beautiful
in a way that's also pure and lovely but
I'm like we've all just been inundated
with tech now that that's kind of very
nice to hear yeah I mean I do get asked
like how did
you do this acting sequence and I'll be
like my imagination yeah and it's like
wait like that's really truly so you
didn't realize that as a young adult
when you thought you were just killing
time you're actually like no sets yeah
right so you went so you get interested
in it and then where do you go you went
into the theater world like how did that
happen so when I was 16 sweet 16 and
never been kissed yeah moved to the
lower 48
Wow see the state of Washington Wow and
must have been a big change it was huge
changed culture shock I had to like take
driving school learn how to drive on a
freeway and you know how to get used to
being anonymous like didn't know where
my house was compared to my school I
mean just you know the suburbs of
Seattle was giant and overwhelming when
you're 16 shopping malls and you know as
my or my acid washed jeans bad there
were like eight years later up there and
so uh and then you know like with bigger
schools people group off mmm in special
interest which I didn't know what I
didn't know what a clinic was Yeah right
so the the girl who was giving me into
her the school she was like you're gonna
hate it here there's so many clicks and
I literally was like what's a quick so I
tried out for a school play and and I
fit in like that felt like oh okay I
found my people right you know this like
the other people using their imagination
yeah you can do this so by the time I
was a senior I guess junior year I was I
played basketball and I was awful I did
in Alaska and I was I was on the varsity
team but junior year I was awful I was
like a great benchwarmer and new year I
finally found it theater I was in a
beautiful 1940s satire Noel Coward
comedy with a horrible British accent I
just owned it and I'm like you write
fashion and I was prancing around the
stage
yeah so that was it and then went to
college did theater okay and then I've
got more into your niche there involved
yeah and then you know a couple of years
between there and grad school I had to
sort of get some more courage like this
is what I'm gonna do
yeah I mean I think that's the talking
to a lot of people that's the biggest
step is like there's this imposter
syndrome that we all have and then like
really just convincing yourself to go
taking the leap yeah I think at that age
too I was like looking for people to
tell me oh you should do this he's gonna
do that yeah if anything my parents are
like how are you gonna make a living
what is the practical right here which
is great because they you know I
appreciate that now yeah cuz it made me
really do it for me like I really had to
find it your resolve in myself yeah that
is true you really have to admit to your
son but even in failure this is the
option for you right yeah and that's
hard to admit yeah and very scary
especially at that time too so you did
you went to grad school you went to like
a conservatory right the American
Conservatory Theater
yes disco what is that exactly it's a
servitor II it sounds very like a place
where you get a master's degree it's
just a master's program okay
conservatories just fancy words sounds
very fancy it is they audition all over
the country I think they're they accept
like 20 22 students so it's it's quite a
big deal when you get accepted to one of
these programs and I had audition for a
whale and NYU and Julliard and a CT so
sort of pick the top ones around the the
country and and got in and went there
and then after grad school I just packed
up a u-haul my dad actually helped me
pack up a u-haul and we motor to LA Wow
they moved to LA not knowing anybody yet
well this seems like a theme in your
life but this way yes these big moves to
other cities yeah so what was the
transition like to Los Angeles pregnant
was sounds like it was great it was a
little bit of a slow start for me I mean
just I think getting acclimated I got a
job waiting tables right away
paying the rent she went on a lot of
auditions a lot of auditions yeah
started a book after a couple of years
but you know I really didn't know
anybody I had I had to had some
representation from some showcases that
we did from the grad school program and
then you know slowly started to sort of
I mean just hustle oh yeah you do yeah
when you don't know anybody in a big
city and you have it you know and this
dream all pre social media yeah so you
really have to like put your feet on the
ground yeah literally and go to every
audition to everything that comes up
yeah
how have you seen because it is
interesting because you're very active
on social media which is very cool and
you use it very authentically I feel
like it's not like you you don't look at
your Instagram or Twitter and think that
you're like passing your phone off is
someone to post for you like yeah I was
like it's front of you it is yeah how
has that been incorporated into your
world
it's been it's a it's to me it's an
ongoing relationship yeah I mean it I
feel like I continue to kind of redefine
it I really got on to social media when
scandal came about and we did life
tweeting with fans you know it was a
network show so it was like every
Thursday night yeah 9 o'clock 10 o'clock
or you know East Coast West Coast we
were we had a real specific engagement
it was like sweatpants pizza yeah life
tweeting and then when that ended I was
like okay well and and really also
there's like a you know there's just
sort of a rhythm that I was in and I
stepped away from it actually for a
little bit which was nice just a little
unplug yeah I got his Mobile's I planted
a huge vegetable garden they stopped
watching all TV except for documentaries
and I read yeah and I and they fed your
brain yeah I did and then I was like oh
you know I could use a little more sense
of humor here yeah so I've sort of added
that in a little bit and um I just try
to keep it real I mean right yeah it's
all you can do just and so when you say
it feels like it's it's
like I'm not reading something that a
staff is doing yeah staffs not doing it
very very much it's very refreshing okay
we're gonna take a quick break when we
get back I have to ask you about your
style because just watching all of your
outfits for all of these carpeted events
is so awesome
so we'll be right back with more not too
deep today we have support from one of
our dear friends that like to turn your
dreams into realities we're talking
about Squarespace they make it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
do you want to start a new business
showcase your work published content
sell products or more Squarespace is the
tool for you and this might be the exact
time to be pursuing all of those dreams
that beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can make a beautiful website
all by yourself they also have powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online and analytics that
help you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box and there is nothing to
patch or upgrade ever buying domains is
simple you can get the help you need
with their 24/7
award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people from
designers to lawyers artists to gamers
restaurants and gyms and maybe you to
turn great ideas into something real
head to squarespace.com slash grace for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain again that squarespace.com
slash grace offer code grace okay we're
back and I gotta talk about your fashion
sense I think it's so cool I think it's
so unique isn't that good I just think
it's very it is a little unique how do
you describe your fashion sense I see a
lot of pant suits well right now right
now there's been a lot of pansies
probably more than ever and that's sort
of not on purpose like last night I was
going to
this purple cocktail oh that's all your
story yeah yeah and and you want to know
something I had this weird feeling then
something was gonna go wrong and we
never have backup outfits and so I
texted my stylist and said hey you know
there's that one dude that we didn't
need altering can you just bring that
just in case
and sure enough we're zipping up the
dress and it's like this isn't yeah I
can't and so then there you see another
pantsuit which is why I loved it if you
guys haven't seen it go check it out on
her Instagram it's got feathers it's
it's very fun it's very cool and you
know we're not we're not shaking hands
right now we're doing the elbow bun so I
had fun I had a feathered elbow bug
everybody was WWE Charlotte Flair it was
very cool but I feel like this is the
week you know it ends on Friday the 13th
we've had a full moon right who knows
what Mercury's gonna make ya so I feel
like we're all a little witchy this week
that's right but I love it I think you
have a very unique style and a lot of
people have commented on it I think
that's very fun do you are you into
fashion are you do I love fashion I love
I love having fun with it and I work
with a couple of stylist Danny and Emma
and they we've worked together for years
and they they get me and you know it's
it's a collaboration for sure um but
again I like to have fun and a little
bit of a sense of humor with it as well
yeah there was a phase where I felt like
I was taking it a little seriously and
then that can just get to be sure it's
why yeah I mean you know you're not
gonna please everybody right they're
gonna be who go on there and be like
good god what is this woman doing
yeah it's truly impossible to please
everyone so as long as you're having fun
I'm feeling good how do you cuz you've
done so many events and so many things
now what's your prep do you have a like
a system do you do some deep breathing
do you just say [ __ ] it like we're doing
it again here we go uh I don't have a a
big routine I mean I definitely try to
eat a nice big meal before this thing
happens because you know I mean
Bendu a number of these you you
basically there is no food yeah or if
there is food you're far away from it
yes or they won't let you eat it because
you're having a photo right or the thing
that you're wearing
yeah right or yeah there's so many
reasons and so fuel up and then you know
surround myself with cool people yeah I
think that's probably like hair makeup
stylist like again people who just want
to have a good time yeah and and and you
know I worked some with some really
great people so it's that and then I
think also if I'm going on a corporate
and doing a press line it's sort of nice
to know you know to have just my
thoughts together but it's probably
those three things and that's and that's
it that makes sense
yeah because it's such a circus I feel
like people see these still images from
an event and it looks very controlled
and you look at it so we bring up
together and the before and after of
that singular moment it's so chaotic
so just there's so much noise yeah
there's so much out of the frame of the
photo that you're seeing that's
happening around you yet that's well
said well just so I always look at it
I'm like there's so much more happening
that we can't see much so fascinating -
yeah yeah that you're just trying to
stay focused and get your focus on this
one lens that's looking at ya
you also have star girl is that yes
already it streams Friday the 13th March
13th this Friday ok I guess this will
come oh yes I'm aiming and streaming
it's out there it's on Disney Plus on
Disney bus and it stars grace van der
Waal and cranbersher
it's kind of this coming-of-age story of
this very ordinary boy in this very
ordinary town of Mike Arizona and I play
his very ordinary mom and then star girl
comes down out of town with her ukulele
and she just bends the whole place they
just and the message which I love about
this movie is really like don't be
afraid to be yourself and be a unique
snowflake like be someone who's just
like a little she's a little out there
she's like a little weird and a little
not grace star girl yeah yeah but but
you know she has this infectious
effect over the whole town and and and
of course of course he falls in love
with or the boy and and so it's a sweet
movie yeah it's another one that like
everybody can watch that's great it also
feels very in line with the your story
yeah you know your real life story a
little bit which is very fun is there
any difference in working on something
for a Disney plus versus Netflix or is
it all kind of the same thing yeah not
so much it it's um for me it's just
about the creators and the showrunners
and the directors and and I've just been
really fortunate I keep working with
really fantastic directors Julia Hart
who directed Star girl and and and our
show runners for lock and key and the
directors they had I mean it's just you
know and Shonda Rhimes for scandal I
mean I've just been truly hashtag
blessed there you go to work with great
people that's awesome
I watched the the little trailer for
star girl yeah already feels very
emotional it was very sweet and it yeah
it feels like they snuck an Indian yeah
I don't get to see Indies very much in
here anymore and that's what I love
about these streaming services like
there's a place for them to live now
yeah and that's truly one of those that
I think do you you've been doing this
for so long I always like asking if you
have a horror auditioning story or
anything that comes to mind about it I
have a couple I know we like it Barry
the really dramatic no I have a really
great one that I've shared before but
not here okay um
it was my audition for scandal actually
and Shonda Rhimes is in the room her
producing partner Betsy bear's casting
director and the director and I was I
was in a turtleman of turtlenecks yeah
II am wearing one now I'm very much like
I was wearing a blue
knit turtleneck under this suit and I
was doing this monologue that Shawna had
wrote I had the hots for this guy and I
was describing him as you know smelling
like apples and man and I decided to
this was planned to sort of pole at the
at the you know collar of my turtleneck
as I say this and I ripped this giant
hole right in the middle and it was so
into the audition I didn't realize I'm
saying there was a gaping hole in me and
I you know I got the role of Abby Whelan
which is great but I noticed it that's
amazing
and also it's what I worked out I'm
really glad it worked out I'm also
interested to know that there's probably
that footage in the east where some way
which I'm sure is so fun to rewatch now
going oh I wanted to ask you about this
documentary that you did pure leaf yes
yeah when did you do this this was a
documentary about the TV yes I did it on
a hiatus I think during season six of
scandal I think it was six okay yes it
was six because that's when I started to
direct for Shonda directed a digital
miniseries for the scandal website and I
sort of did him both back-to-back but
yes and went to Indonesia with the P
relief team and how did we come about
well I so for a while I was posting a
lot of food stuff on my Instagram okay
and I was yelling women asked about the
grapefruit we'll get to that a little
bit okay for a while okay so like while
I was doing scandal like to unwind I did
a lot of gardening okay and that turned
into like I have all this great fresh
veg so I'm gonna start to like cook and
make recipes and then you know I got
carried away and instagrammed everything
yeah suddenly Rachael Ray is like can I
produce a cookbook of yours Wow and it
was great but I was like I don't like I
won't just want to be an actor
anything's for me I don't need to
monetize my fists right now but it but I
did I was like looking like quite a
foodie and and I met the pure leaf
people and they were like well you know
we're looking for someone who's really
into food and beverage in like you know
adventure and I love travel and I had
been doing travel for I did a
documentary in Alaska as well and cool
and had done some traveling in the
Middle East for another film I did and
so so it just sort of aligned and they
were like we were looking we have a tea
expert he's amazing and he truly is like
a tea expert from England who's like he
drinks like 300 cups of tea a day Wow
knows all the different kinds and so I
went with him he works for pure leaf and
we went to Indonesia to a tea estate and
we we learned how to is sort of I mean
he knew he was he kind of showed and and
the worst not processed but you know how
it's sort of made into a dry leaf that
you can brew and that was what the
documentary was and then I ended up like
making some recipes for their website oh
that were sort of Indonesian cuisine I'm
inspired from being there wow that was
really fun it was like a very organic
collaboration it was it was you know
most people go to Indonesia and they go
to Bali and they said I'm the beach for
48 hours and you know and have beautiful
Instagram yes and mine was like in a
tiny village and I could and we did this
documentary in this rainforest in this
village and I couldn't wash my hair the
whole time because there were no blow
dryers and it was so muddy that if I
washed it at night even the next morning
waking up it'd still be wet right so I
had like 10,000 pounds of dry shampoo on
top of dry shampoo uh-huh so check it
out my hair looks amazing
you have to be interested in tea watch
my hair journey yeah no makeup people
were out in the jungle so I was doing it
all well hi guys there for two weeks
cool well it was fun that's and where is
it is it out in the world for people to
see no well it was living on their
website okay here leaf website and it
it what it did air on not the Discovery
Channel but another light was like yeah
it was like a channel that's like that
you really curates really great
documentary ok very cool it was a while
ago so well go look find it on the
Internet yeah just Google Darby
Stanchfield shampoo let's go back for a
second so you're you you like to cook
you like to to garden tell me about the
origin of this this grapefruit
fascination yeah on your if you guys
look under Instagram there's a tab on
our stories that's you explaining the
proper way to cut a grape for the most
brilliant waiting I mean it changes your
life what you see I've had so many
people say like I'll never look at a
grapefruit the same way ever again come
to fruition did someone just watch you
cut a grapefruit one day and well no
it's my dad my dad Tommy
oak my dad came up with us I say in the
tutorial like I'm sure he's not the only
one who's ever just come up with this
but he you should see him carpet Turkey
thank you there's not one little art
he's like he puts Benihana to [ __ ] he's
truly like and he's a fisherman yeah so
he can fillet a fish like anyway so he
takes those skills and he does this with
her brave fruit and he has the most
giant grapefruit tree in his yard that
produces over 100 I mean they can never
eat enough he and my mom so they're
always giving me bags of grapefruit so I
was in Toronto shooting lock-and-key it
was dead of winter
I was I was sort of I had isolated
myself on purpose doing one of these
actory things about like the characters
isolated I mean I think so I was going
out of my head so I decided to do a
tutorial I'd never done one I obviously
felt very silly so I break into laughter
doing it but yeah I'm actually very
proud of it so I put it up there because
I thought you know it's you can learn
something you can be entertained if you
need a laugh yeah it's actual education
right it's very fun are we going to see
more of this I I tried but there's I
don't think there's anything that can
really compare I mean
once you you know I've tried and I've
had you know people that I really
respect saying no no it's not it's not
nearly as good as that one so I'll put
it up for two seconds and then take it
down so what um on social media are
there any people that you love to follow
are there any like accounts that you're
obsessed with for better or worse gosh I
mean I know it's so inundated and so
overwhelming open up your apps but
really really yeah
[Music]
right I mean this sounds so it is it's
very isolating but right now I'm having
the best time
just with my cast mates on lock and key
zone a they're so funny yeah that's what
I love about it they make me scream a
lot so like and they have the best sort
of behind the scenes footage or like
it's just their silly comments like it's
it's it brings me like deep laughter
yeah just just you know and we just
released the show like a month ago and
so there's like all this am I putting
out dude so I'm just sort of in a little
bromance bubble right now so if you ask
me later I'll have something like sure
no but this makes sense
do they are there strict guidelines on
how much like BTS stuff you guys can put
up or they just kind of like put up that
ever you want earlier yeah wow that's
cool like oh yeah be real people yeah
and I'd spread the word with one set and
you only get along this is great yeah
and the fact that it was like make city
like yeah we're just playing right now
like a you know you just keep thinking
if you were totally miserable and then
had to do that house yeah exactly
are there any rumblings of more or you
guys kind of just sit right now I'm sort
of wait we're waiting for like we should
be hearing soon by the time the streams
actually I think we will have heard okay
so I say why delighting in the great
anticipation so you were
going back a little bit - you said you
were directing as a gladiator wanted was
the what was your first thing that I
directed yes what is that like going
from because sometimes I think about
directing and it's so overwhelming to
even wrap my brain around that how was
that for you that was the first thing
that you had ever directed I had ever
directed yeah okay first of all it's
Shonda land yeah yeah and she just sets
the table so nicely for all sorts of
people who want to try new things and
she's a very she's a big champion of
women hmm expanding and developing the
careers so not only does she write well
for women but she behind the scenes is
like oh oh I see that you're shadowing
all the directors and that you're
interested which is what I had been
doing sitting at video village you know
really sort of tombery car producing
director at the time Tony Goldwyn who's
on the show who - who's a director
really like spending a lot of time with
them and she noticed and and this
project came along and it was it was for
the website of scandal and it was like
here's your budget and her she had some
producers specifically on the project
and when they present it same to me I
was like okay so what am I gonna do act
and they're like pretty much anything
you want well I also got to help Co
develop it so I pitched them an idea I
was like okay give me 48 hours it went
away and it came back with this idea of
like gladiator school like Millennials
who are trying out to be like crisis
management fixers yeah and Olivia Pope's
out of the office and we need more help
and charlie one of the gladiators is
gonna film it on his little like
camcorder which won't give it its unique
sort of differentiate it from the show
right but still sort of be tied to the
show so I pitched that and they were
like great work that we're gonna get a
writer on it and then we all worked on
it and he wrote and we all got notes
from Shonda and Betsy beers and and then
it ended up with a six-part series and
we shot it in a couple of days with a
skeleton crew Wow and it was I have to
say
I I was definitely nervous sure for that
for the first days specifically but I
was also so supported that after like an
hour I was like oh okay I can breathe
yeah and then the next season that was
like during season six during her hiatus
I got to shoot that and then season
seven Shauna gave me an episode like how
cool is that not even the lead of the
show like she gave Kerry Washington who
was a lead prey of our show an episode
and she gave me an episode of television
with like a million you know
multi-million dollar budgets you even
respond to that off with attitude and I
was like I remember writing her an email
and I was like I will do the best I can
I promise
and I had the best time I had like you
know charts and ideas and and and the
best dps and the best career I mean it's
just that's another like yeah it was
another dream cast and so and I actually
did sleep the night before my first day
I guess I had had you know this yeah
this digital miniseries sort of under my
belt and I'd continued to shadow and it
also feels like a really nice fit for me
mm-hm like I really feel I felt good in
that position yeah confident confident
and I felt okay this is why I was
confident because I'm like I'm not try
to ask for any help that's you know if
the DP has a great idea like I'm not
gonna pretend like I know everything
that's great yeah I think is always
great leadership position like don't be
afraid to sort of ask for help when you
need it or delegate or like let's figure
this out together these are my ideas
what are your ideas yeah and I think
that's something that seems like such a
simple concept but I'm sure a lot of
people you know kind of resist that
because being in charge you think that
you should have all the answers when
really you should have a plan
yeah there's you know I think I mean
when I this doesn't happen often but
sometimes we'll work with the director
and they have no prep and I'm like 14
hours kind of the table
something's know that makes sense also
it seems like I'm sure for the crew and
cast you that you know you feel like
you're all in it together when ideas are
heard and respected yeah and that sort
of thing absolutely and I there there's
a morale booster there I think too when
people feel like they get to contribute
and like I mean people are there because
they're good right you know they're I
mean yeah are there for a reason like
utilize them and yeah and see them yeah
um that's nice it seems like there's a
lot of respect in that world a very cool
thing um are there any more directing
things in the future coming up it's been
tough I will say it's been tough I've
been in conversations with people I've
put it out there I would like for it to
happen
but I don't have anything like concrete
that I can tell you like I think this
next you know you're gonna well it also
feels like you've been very busy right
now
I love Janet Lee I've been very very
busy acting and and and and that's my
first love so yeah I'm not gonna
complain that's great yeah but to direct
more in the future yeah we're putting
that out there
we're putting energy behind there that
everybody gray says well see what
happens okay we're gonna take one last
break when we get back we have a ton of
Twitter questions for you so we'll be
right back with more not too deep sports
research is your one-stop-shop for a
lifetime of performance health and
wellness through the makers of the
highest-rated collagen peptide product
on Amazon and their flagship product
sweet sweat sweating helps burn calories
and sweet sweat activated by your
elevated heart rate helps increase
sweating during exercise
look at this science you can simply
apply the gel which comes in a variety
of pleasing sense too slow to respond
problem areas before your workout for
best results use sweet sweat in
combination with sports researches
best-selling waist trimmers like their
new neon waist trimmer collection and
did you know that collagen is vital to
help support the health of your skin
hair nails and connective tissues well
that's why
try sports researches third party
certified and non-gmo verified collagen
peptides which provide the best product
at the best price offered in a variety
of flavors sports research collagen
peptides can be added to coffee soup
sauces or more at home or on-the-go look
at all of these treasures for you and
you have a special offer coming your way
if you go to sports research comm and
use the code grace at checkout right now
you'll get 20% off your order that's 20%
off site-wide at sports research comm
with code grace at checkout we're
talking about third love today a company
that is here to support you in so many
ways designed with measurements from
millions of women third loves bra styles
are made to fit your life they have over
80 bra sizes but know that the only one
that matters is yours I've talked about
my experience with third love before big
big fan as a person that values comfort
over fashion I could say that these bras
are extremely comfortable and also very
fashionable it's hands down the most
comfortable bra that your own they have
straps that don't slip they have tag
list labels it's ingenious and they have
lightweight memory foam cups that mold
to your shape plus returns and exchanges
are free and easy in fact thinks that
their loves perfect fit promise every
customer has 60 days to months to wear
the bra wash the bra and put it to the
test and if you don't love it you can
return it and third love will wash it
and donate it to a woman in need it's
win win win win win win win all the way
around third love knows there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they're offering you guys 15% off your
first order go to 3rd love.com slash
grace now to find your perfect fitting
bra and get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love.com
slash grace for 15% off today okay we're
gonna get into Twitter questions in one
moment I'm gonna ask you first the two
questions that I ask every single guest
that is on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti act
Shakespeare oh cool I don't know that
we've had that would he duck not me I
don't exist yeah it's busy incognito I
don't know would you get the right
person is there wouldn't stick to is
like stringing her right I have so many
questions I feel like you'd throw it and
then you'd have a sit-down interview I
love that answer
okay the other question is to tell us
your worst pants shooting story or like
close call but you can only use three
words or three small phrases so mine is
college jogging front lawn a true time
[Laughter]
so many years said so it's all good mmm
okay airplane Oh 100-foot drop
does that count yeah yeah there we go
Wow Wow
well I'm glad that you're here today
[Laughter]
whoo okay no follow-up questions okay
let's get into these Twitter questions
yeah I'm up Twitter Catherine wants to
know what's your favorite piece of
clothing it would have to be a
turtleneck okay a classic I mean I'm
sort of into those right now I sort of
also know they're out there right now
but Catherine as you can see if you're
watching you may just only be listening
if you're listening today I am wearing a
leopard print Cheryl neck it's lovely
can't go wrong and I feel like they
never truly go out of style to 80s they
were huge the 90s I think they were
they're back they're here now
okay just wants to know who is your
fashion icon cuz mine is you oh nice
well I have a few but one of them that
comes to mind is Tilda Swinton she's
sick fashion yeah I can see that I mean
she's sort of you
no she's she's she's like an alien or
unicorn she's like otherworldly yeah
like I mean it in the best way oh I
think everything she wears I just like I
I just want to be her I feel like that's
how everyone describes her - I was like
you can't fully understand her but
that's why you're you want to continue
to try - yeah this is what I like about
it I feel like she just makes everything
cool she is so cool she makes everything
cool
and she also like what she wears always
makes her even more mysterious and
interesting yeah yes like this and I do
feel like she has a sense you her about
it - I do - I feel like she's she
understands how people interpret her
yeah and she doesn't she kind of leans
into it yeah not so much no there's
something relaxed about yeah like she
doesn't like it's not too fussy I just
yeah I mean I wish she's a dream guest
but I feel like it would also just be
okay sitting in silence with her for an
hour and just consider that in episode
because let's put that out there yeah
she seems like someone that could
communicate with her mind and that would
be very cool she does in that one Marvel
movie yes the one the one with my robot
yeah there are yeah and the red lamp
yeah the one with the glove and the
jewels and the leather yeah someone has
a shield I don't know Kate wants to know
what character have you played that you
relate most to and vice versa
I guess what you know you could relate
least - hmm okay this is a such a nerdy
answer but truly it's whatever I'm
working on at the moment
mhm like it's really like I can't I've
been fortunate that none of my
characters have really been the same
same
they've all been yeah quite different
but you know I think to find the story
like I always look for a set you know
like what what
fall in love with the character and then
when Swartz the hook or what's the sort
of heart or the anchor of the character
and then then that feels like a similar
thing in that you know I'm finding a way
to connect our lover my compassion for
it but then like like differences like
for Nina would be like I'm not a mom I
don't want weights or Abby Whelan you
know I wouldn't I mean I don't TV hair
combs helmet of TV hair unless you're
doing a documentary mission a madman
with the antique lighter and the smoking
and the long nails it's you know there's
a bunch of differences but it sounds
like even what you said that when you
were isolating and created the great
great fruit content of our generation um
that you do take the time to like sit
and find the complexity and the people
that you're protecting I try to yeah
yeah I mean I yeah and when I'm given
time like for lock and key
you know it was here's five scripts and
we're gonna get five more right away so
there was time to I mean as we were
shooting I was like I had I knew what
the full thing was and there was time to
really sort of plan and think about this
arc you know Nina has a breaking point
so you're right I do I like to I like to
go deep on not so deep that's great um
and I think probably what helps you
shine in these characters do you take
time afterwards when you're wrapped to
like decompress out of the character do
you what do you do when you rat what do
you do for fun it's different you know
some of it's um gosh like scandal we
shot almost ten months out of the year
so it's an ongoing thing so it's really
about decompressing after of day of
being on set like on the way home you
know just listening to some great music
and getting out of high heels and you
find a way to sort of punch in and punch
out I think a little bit more you have
to yeah but when we did and scandal I
did I mentioned that like I went on a
big unplug like I really disengaged to
the point where I was I also sort of did
see my castmates for a couple of months
hmm iced I I just stayed home and I was
like barefoot I think for in overall
gardening and cooking and watching
documentaries and I think part of it was
like I was so afraid that it was gonna
be like this heartbreak this cuz we had
so much fun I was like I'm gonna rip the
band-aid off now mm-hmm and I also like
really need to get a be out of my system
and later for seven years
Wow if I can't pick up another script I
just go into the same speech pattern and
you know look for the hairspray and I so
and you know Nina's so different lock
and key it was an even when we were
shooting on like I gotta slow down I
gotta slow down that's good to recognize
too I mean playing a character for seven
years
yeah I I can't imagine but also you
probably really have to find the time to
find yourself yeah every now I'd be like
is is there still a hard and fast line
between me and her or also just kind of
getting some normal it was nice to get
out of the grind of of Hollywood and
shooting and just and just feel like I
could just like a completely you know I
don't know yeah like almost boring like
let's just go low-key for a while no
that's great what's your favorite food
to garden what's the most successful
it's a garden uh well the easiest is
herbs I mean half of them that I grow or
like I mean I have nothing now because I
was in Toronto shooting for lock and key
and so there's nothing yeah
just a bunch of dead oregano but but the
herbs are drought tolerant so they were
the easiest yeah but I had fun lat right
after scandal I had planted all these
cucumbers and they they went nuts I mean
I had for a while I don't know why I
took it down but I had this post I had a
cucumber that was like the shape of a
telephone like wrapped around my face
like I only do it for seven million
and it doesn't exist online anymore I
took it off I was like that's it was one
of those bad I did a social media wipe
and that's good every now and then I
mean I but that one I'm too far into my
life online to even attempt to go back
and clean things up at this point it's
like it's there I can't do anything
staying on scandal for a second city
wants to know what's your favorite
storyline or what was your favorite
storyline to do in scandal there's too
many yeah many I mean one episode I
really enjoyed it was it was very much
an abbey episode it was um you know she
gets into trouble she gets a little
power-hungry she's chief of staff of the
White House at the time wait a minute
is she still chief of staff yes and she
gets a little power-hungry and she gets
her her her her fellow gladiator in
trouble he almost gets killed Huck truly
I had death warnings online really yes
equator on social media people were so
mad that I almost felt like that they
were coming for me they were like I'm
gonna come to LA I'm gonna hunt you down
Wow I know where you live and kill you
that oh I mean okay things about that is
one you know that means kudos to you've
created such a fantasy world that's so
real for these people that they want to
take action against you and to yeah
maybe a time to disconnect from the
internet a little bit well I give all
the credit to Shonda Rhimes people who
wrote it and everybody who shot it I
mean they really were the ones who
created the world yeah um
but in that episode there's I'm I get to
dig for a bullet and I mean this is part
of the reason why I was like my favorite
episode ever
I get blackmail I gotta go get this
bullet out of this this Vice President
who got killed classic right he got
murdered at the assassinated it is
inauguration you know typical day for
the position and I'm in there digging
for this bullet uh and it was the most
fun ever I was going on like no sleep
and it was like my fourth day of like 15
hours of shooting and I was shaking at
the time and it was this whole
it was a hole I'll never forget it how
tiga Nights really wasn't how fun it was
digging in a fake cadaver for suit or
something bra tears I don't know what it
was beautiful I mean the symbolism of
all of that and then the death threats
it was all very special wow wow what a
moment Emma wants to know would Abby
Whelan and Nina Locke be friends I I
don't I don't know in what world they
would ever meet I know what uh-huh Nina
Locke would get in trouble and and Abby
would need to help fix her or something
what they get along
Nina apologizes for herself a lot and
Abby doesn't apologize so I think you
know they've been an interesting Daniel
a clash a little actually okay yeah I'm
having a real I'm you truly trying to
imagine I can see where your imagination
is so strong because you're I can
constructing a world in your net in
which these two storylines cross over I
want to see the Saturday Night Lights
can yeah
Alissa is asking which key is your
favorite which would you most like to
use be anywhere key is the sexiest key
you take this ski uh-huh you put it in a
door you all you have to do is know
where the other places and that there is
a door there and you open the door and
you get to be there so can you imagine
you could just go anywhere teleportation
it yes totally yeah and you just cut
down on all that flying and airports and
oh my gosh you know she is a pre-check
but for people that don't know from lock
and key like the basic premise of the
show if they haven't gotten into it yet
is essentially like the family takes
over this bonkers house yeah so I play
the matriarch of this Locke family we we
witnessed the brutal murder of Brenda
lock their dad these three kids dad we
go back to his ancestral home just like
start over maybe find some answers
what happened and this house is key
house and it's alive its alive it has
these magic keys that whisper to the
kids and each time the kids find a new
key it has a whole special set of powers
magical powers that it unlocks and so
that's basically the premise it don't
take you that it's a good bin I'm into
it
this is polarizing emmalin is asking
who's your favorite cast member on lock
and key but that's I'm sure hard to pick
no I I couldn't pick really and I'm and
that's like a great answer to truly have
cuz everybody's so cool yeah that's
right Nicky says no question just want
to say Abbie deserve better I'm telling
you when I was at the gravesite of David
Rosen when we went to go shoot this and
uh before the cameras started rolling
I'm bawling my eyes out and the director
Tom Erica he's like that but you know
you can't cry in the scene like I know
let me just get it I gotta get it out
right now I'm attached kate says what
was the process of live tweeting with
fans each week like sweatpants some
really good nachos or pizza or something
I meal or something out of my garden
like a giant cucumber and then you know
really sitting down and live tweeting
real-time with fans so night and it was
so fun the gladiators were just I mean
they're they were so into it it was
really good it's also cool social mean
that's cool for that sense of like you
really get to interact yeah the fans you
really get to see what they care about
and how they respond to the show in real
time - yeah and it's for me it's the
closest like digitally as the closest
experienced doing theater in which you
have a live audience reaction so you're
getting it sort of like wow they're
watching the show you're getting an
audience reaction yeah I've never
thought really it's really fun that
makes total sense
Stephanie Darby are you going to bring
back meatless Monday recipes see what
did I tell you I put a lot of food okay
this is what the people want
now there's this okay oh I Stephanie I'm
just gonna tease this one thing that I'm
making it's with beets pumpkin seeds and
buckwheat and I blend it up with some
coconut oil and make a pizza out of it
and just cook it or not it it might be
Wow I haven't instagrammed it because
I'm done don't want to make a recipe but
yeah I mean maybe I do someday but now
right now no now's not the time but
it'll still be there oh let's see Bali
loves SX is saying congrats on the
success of the show what shows do you
watch on Netflix
have you seen cheer yes cheer is the
best it's wonderful I watched it all in
one day
have you had Jerry here yet no I think
Jerry's too busy I mean if he's not at
the Oscars he's right today I mean the
network's building is across the street
I know like they're always some Harry
Jerry put another tilda swinton yes and
jerry together hopefully on one episode
that would be truly idea i think we'd
have to take up can i play this good i
have two you'd have to have yeah you can
sit here in the corner okay great yeah I
love cheer were you into did you I
didn't do any cheerleading in high
school no oh you know what
yeah remember small fishing town Laska
okay so when I moved to Dutch Harbor
Alaska which is even further out okay in
the middle of nowhere
none of the high school girls wanted to
be cheerleaders and remember there's
like you know maybe twelve people seven
people per class nobody want to be
cheerleaders so there were like three of
us in middle school who said well
cheerlead so in middle school I got to
be cheerleader okay huge thick glasses
long pleated skirt that went to my knees
it was way too big they didn't give us
new you know I was like here's old
uniforms that are 15-20 years old you
can be cheerleaders and we I didn't know
what I was doing but I felt so beautiful
I had the feathered hair
streeted skirt that was giant iconic so
you know you do have a connection to
cheer that I was I was a horrible
cheerleader but don't but you know what
I had team spirit like Jerry but yeah I
did I was like that's to hear it
everybody on it sounds like - you're
bringing that sense of cheerleading to
every set that you're on as well so it
lives within you
well Prometheus fire says when was the
last time your heart was filled to
bursting with love for someone or
something very intense question every
day every day you know with someone
something that's why not right that's
beautiful live with gratitude and on the
opposite end of that oh I think this is
our last question what's the most
embarrassing thing that has ever
happened to her on set or while filming
hmm sure there's so many things I mean
also you're towing the lemons kind of
awful but it wasn't embarrassing for me
but I felt horrible
okay so scandal against scandal I at one
point I had to slap Josh Molina who
played David Rosen like on and off again
love interest the one who ends up dead
at the end of this spoilers series I had
to slap him really hard in this it was
kind of a sexy sexy know where I
basically slap him stuff a bunch of
fingers in his mouth shove him behind a
sofa and then you know yeah he'd get and
we get busy I was so afraid that I
wasn't that I couldn't slap I was really
afraid of her hurting him yes I wasn't
slapping him very hard and so then I
overcompensated and one time I didn't
slap Murari so I slapped him twice he
looked at me like he wanted to kill
everybody's like what are you doing
beating up on the after I don't what do
you want from me
oh that's great I also love that
hesitation and then but like that I do
it a second taken get fired oh that's so
right thank you again for being here
this is been so lovely before you go um
every guess it's on the podcast gets a
personalized fortune cookie I've been
waiting for from us to you I know just
sits here for you to stare at awkwardly
in the whole time but inside is a
personalized for it I can do it now
right you can do it right now
okay is this like a monologue yahoo
Shakespeare right having Yuri audition
for the conservatory right now and
Shakespeare wrote it right yeah we've
been Wow okay this is my fortune okay
there will be about at least 30 kids who
will misspell the word
lock on their upcoming spelling exams
we're not saying it's your shows fault
per se unless yeah that's a tough thing
maken-ki I know honey I know that damn
okay what's coming up for you where can
people find everything that's out now if
they don't know yes lock and key it's on
Netflix now binge the first 10 episodes
I have star girl on Disney Plus which
you can also well I guess do you been
jammu V it's a movie it's a fantastic
movie on Disney Plus and an indie I did
called Justine which is also on Netflix
streaming on Netflix and it's a
beautiful film that deals with racism
and disabilities and families and how
they deal really unique and refreshing
movie Wow
basically there's something for everyone
yeah as well just go to Netflix and is
new classy and what's your social media
people want to check in is my social
media stuff yes Facebook Instagram
Twitter it's all Darby s official okay
Darby's official there you go easy
amazing thank you again for being here
you guys go to Netflix check it all out
you'll love it
or we'll be creeped out by it but
there's a love somewhere in there and
we'll see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye too deep
too deep
go deep deep not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer Melissa D months edited by
Shireen Lonnie Eunice post production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music
[Music]